on attend le verdict d'une secondeune
minute à l'autre de la Cour de Justice
de la République concernant Éric duup
Moretti il est soupçonné d'avoir usé de
ses fonctions pour régler ses comptes
avec des magistrats on va revenir sur
tout ça bien évidemment mais on va
parler de ce sujet pour en parler je
suis avec Arnaud Benedetti bonjour
bonjour à vous vous êtes politologue
professeur associé à son et rédacteur en
chef de la revue Politique et
parlementairire j'invite no internautes
bien sûr à poser leurs questions on y
répond au mieux comme d'habitude le le
verdict devrait tomber d'ici quelques
instants un procès du ministre de la
Justice un ministre de la justice devant
la justice c'est quand même pas banal
comme comme situation ça doit être à peu
près unique dans les anales de la
République en effet s effet un vrai
sujet d'ailleurs depuis le début comment
un ministre de la Justice inquiété par
la justice peut-il rester en fonction
c'est une question en tout cas qui a été
posée par un certain nombre
d'observateurs et de commentateurs et
aussi d'acteurs politiques le président
de la République et la première ministre
ont tranché mais le moment de vérité
arrive aujourd'hui pour le garde des
siau monsieur Dupont moréti oui il
arrive maintenant on l'aura d'ici
quelques instants on a vu Éric Dion
Moretti rentrer dans la salle il y aura
forcément l'annonce puis ensuite les
réaction on l'imagine est-ce qu'on peut
rappeler qu'est-ce qu' lui est reproché
à erriic dupéti alors il lui est
reproché sur le fond d'avoir fait
pression dans le cadre de ses fonctions
de garde saau c'est la raison pour
laquelle il se retrouve d'ailleurs
devant la Cour de Justice de la
République puisque la cour de la de
justice de la République est la seule
instance judiciaire à pouvoir poursuivre
des ministres en fonction euh sur des
faits qui seraient répréhensibles
pénalement dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions d'avoir fait pression sur des
magistrats dans la fameuse affaire des
fadettes qui a entraîné d'ailleurs la
condamnation de Nicolas Sarkozi en
première instance il me semble ou même
peut-être en 2uxè instance je ne sais sa
plus exactement
donc le le le le le le garde des saut se
défend bien évidemment depuis le début
d'avoir exercé une quelconque pression
lui ou en tout cas son
administration dans cette dans cette
affaire les magistrats qui sont qui
composent la Cour de Justice de la
République c'est une formation où vous
avez 12 parlementaires hein 6 sénateurs
6 députés puis trois magistrats de
profession vont dans quelques instants
donner leur verdict sur cette affaire
oui ça ça paraît toujours étrange que
des que des que des hommes politiques
finalement statu sur un ministre de la
Justice aussi oui cétait c'est une oui
c'est c'est vrai que c'est c'est c'est
compliqué en même temps on considère
vraisemblablement que pour ce qui
concerne les faits qui sont non
détachables de l'exercice de l'activité
ministériel il est légitime que ce soi
des parlementaires sénateurs et
députés accompagné quand même faut-il le
rappeler par trois magistrats
professionnels qui statuent
sur la culpabilité ou non du ministre en
question euh on pourrait évidemment
considérer que c'est une justice
d'exception puisque ce sont finalement
des pères qui jugent d'une certaine
manière leur père même si là c'est
plutôt des parlementaires qui juge un
ministre mais finalement dans l'exercice
d'une démocratie parlementaire il n'est
pas ch non plus vraisemblablement
contenu de la configuration qui est
celle encore une fois qui consiste à
juger les ministres en fonction des
faits qui sont pleinement inscrits dans
leur mandat que ce soit des
parlementaires qui puissent
éventuellement enfin qui puissent qui
puissent juger les ministrre
effectivement cette cette Cour de
Justice de la République elle est
décriée depuis très longtemps d'ailleurs
il me semble qu'Emmanuel Macron voulait
s'en débarrasser il y a pas si longtemps
que ça non il ne l'a pas fait vous savez
la difficulté toujours c'est comment on
juge le politique d'abord la réalité
c'est que j'allais dire l'instance
suprême qui à un moment donné va juger
le politique qui va le sanctionner ou
voir le reconduire c'est quand même le
suffrage universel ce sont les
électrices et les électeurs bon là on
est avec le cas de ministre monsieur DUP
moriti d'abord n'est pas élu il est
ministre et la Cour de Justice de la
République est certainement une côte mal
taillée vraisemblablement mais force de
constater qu'on a pas trouvé mieux
aujourd'hui comme instance pour pouvoir
juger des ministres encore une fois dans
l'exercice de leur fonction oui parce
qu'ils peuvent pas passer devant des
tribunaux classiqu tout à fait tout à
fait c'est d'une certaine manière la
reconnaissance que le statut de ministre
encore une
fois lorsque des faits peuvent être
pénalement poursuivis en raison de
l'activité minist ministériel ne peut
être jugé que par une cour qui est une
cour spécifique qui est une cour
spéciale hm hm
euh on imagine aussi tout tout toutes
les répercussions que ce que cela va que
ce que que que cela va avoir pour éc
dupontourriti pour aussi Emmanuel Macron
selon ce qui va ce qui va arriver il ne
pourra pas forcément rester au
gouvernement ça c'est la grande question
c'est la grande question que tout le
monde se pose depuis le début de ce
procès dans
l'attente du du verdict de la de la Cour
de Justice de la République est-ce qu'un
ministre si il était condamné qui pusait
garde des saut donc ce n'est pas
n'importe quel ministre peut-il rester
en fonction on voit mal aujourd'hui euh
le le le le ministre de la
Justice conserver sa fonction si les 15
les 15 les 15 juges qui le jugent
aujourd'hui décider de sa culpabilité
après il y a toujours quand même une
procédure pour le ministre qui peut peut
évidemment faire appel mais en
l'occurrence on voit on voit on voit pas
comment aujourd'hui cette fonction est
tenable en cas de de condamnation don
alors d'autant plus qu'on a quand même
un on a un cas alors qui n'est pas tout
à fait similaire mais on a eu un un
ministre dans le
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron monsieur
grisé si je ne m'abuse alors lui qui
n'avait pas été jugé par la Cour de
Justice de la République mais qui avait
été jugé pour des faits qui étaient
détachable en effet de son mandat de de
ministre avait été condamné et il avait
été obligé de démissionner tout de suite
après effectivement al on a beaucoup de
gens dans les commentaires qui me disent
mais je comprends pas pourquoi est-ce
que ils ne veuvent pas être dans la même
pourquoi ils ne peuvent pas être juger
comme des citoyens
lambda la vérité c'est que l'on
considère que encore une fois la
fonction ministérielle
euh vraisemblablement exige que ce soit
une cour qui soit une cour d'une
certaine manière politique he puisque
vous avez des parlementaires qui
aujourd'hui jugent euh pour ce qui
touche attention soyons clair encore une
fois le ministre peut être jugé pour des
faits qui sont totalement détachables
comme n'importe comme n'importe quel
autre
citoyen par par une juridiction
ordinaire la réalité c'est que dans
l'exercice encore une fois du mandat
ministériel le le le on estime que il
faut une cour qui soit une cour
spécifique une cour spéciale la Cour de
Justice de la République qui puisse les
juger euh on va revenir un peu peut-être
sur le parcours de d'Éric DUP Moretti on
le connaît depuis très longtemps c'est
c'est un avocat qui qui est très
important en France et c'est un peu une
prise de guerre finalement d'Emmanuel
Macron pour son gouvernement alors c'est
vrai que quand il a été nommé garde d'
saau il y a maintenant c'était en 2000
je ne me souviens plus exactement en
2018 ou 2019 succédant à Madame Boubé ça
a été pris ça a été ça a surpris parce
que d'abord si vous voulez Dupont moriti
par le caractère qui est le sien et puis
par ses déclarations avait toujours dit
que il n'entendait pas rentrer en
politique et certainement pas encore
moins devenir ministre donc lorsque le
président de la République l'a nommé ça
a créé d'une certaine manière une
surprise il y avait la volonté
vraisemblablement aussi de la part du
président de la République de
rééquilibrer peut-être un peu à gauche
son gouvernement parce que Monsieur
Dupont moriti n'a jamais caché qu'il
était plutôt issu d'une sensibilité de
gauche et puis surtout de faire rentrer
une personnalité dont le charisme le
talent oratoire
l'éloquence j'allais dire la la la
dimension très très très personnelle du
du du personnage venait d'une certaine
manière donner du poids à un
gouvernement qui parfois étit considéré
comme un gouvernement de gens plutôt
techniciens ou voire de politique rallié
au à la à la à la macronie donc cette
touche j'allais dire très charismatique
d'une certaine manière que est allé
chercher Emmanuel Macron en nommant
monsieur Dupont moriti permettait de
redonner j'allais dire du poids dans
tous les sens du terme à ce à ce
gouvernement sauf que Monsieur Dupont
moriti n'est pas politique sauf que
Monsieur Dupont moriti n'a jamais eu de
mandat sauf que Monsieur Dupont moriti
lorsqu'il s'est présenté aux élections
notamment régionales a été battu il
n'est pas le premier avocat bien
évidemment grand avocat à devenir garder
sa l'histoire de la République est
pleine de d'avocats qui ont été Gard des
saut à commencé par Robert Badinter mais
d'autres encore avant lui sous la 3è
République d'autres ténors du barreau
comme maître morofferi ou ou maître
campinki mais qui était il faut jamais
l'oublier eux aussi des hommes
politiques c'est-à-dire qu'ils avaient
des mandats mais il appartient disons à
cette tradition de de de j'allais dire
de grand rur du du du prêtoire qui sont
rentrés en politique la difficulté c'est
que
il y a eu quand même un risque qu'a pris
Emmanuel Macron en nomant Dupont Moretti
d'abord parce que Dupont Moretti est
quelqu'un qui a un caractère que l'on
connaît et qui n'a jamais caché
développer une culture de conflictualité
avec le corps professionnel des
magistrats et d'ailleurs dans sa défense
d'une certaine manière il estime qu'il
est victime d'une Kabale qui est une
cabale politique et que le dossier est
en l'occurrence pour lequel il est
poursuivi dansant la cour de just de la
République et vide de toute matérialité
qui puisse entraîner sa condamnation oui
effectivement lui lui il parle de de de
de voilà de Kabale politique on est
venu
finalement comment comment dire ça les
c'est les les les magistrats il
n'avaient pas une bonne relation avec
eux avant d'être ministre et bizarrement
une fois qu'il est devenu ministre ça
s'est pas vraiment arrangé oui alors
c'est on le savait si vous voulez on
savait que la relation avec avec les les
les magistrats et notamment aussi les
syndicats de magistrat était une une
relation compliquée en même temps il
peut quand même arguer d'un d'un bilan
les moyens indéiablement du ministère de
la Justice on ont cru ces dernières
années il a qu'on le veuille ou non sur
le plan politique même sans être élu
réussi à imposer une voix qui est une
voix personnelle au sein de ce
gouvernement il y en a pas tant que ça
d'ailleurs finalement des voix qui
puissent s'imposer mis à part quelques
politiques comme Gérald daranin ou
éventuellement Bruno Le Maire qui ont
j'allais dire une place spécifique dans
ils sont parce qu'ils ont un capital
politique ils sont autonomes
politiquement il y a peu de ministres
qui sont autonomes politiquement dans ce
gouvernement si vous voulez on a connu
des gouvernements surous la 5e
République où on avait des ministres qui
étaient véritablement autonomes
politiquement qui s'agissent sous les
gouvernements du président mitteran ou
du gouvernement de de Jacques Chirac et
d'autres encore là on a finalement assez
peu de politiques qui disposent de cette
autonomie lui il n'est pas politique
mais il dispose d'une autonomie qui est
lié à son parcours personnel il est
quand même identifié comme ceux qui font
partie des des grands des grands maîtres
du barreau il a réussi un certain nombre
de prouesses sur le plan judiciaire que
chacun s'accorde à lui reconnaître un
talent évident à la fois dans la
technicité des dossiers mais aussi dans
la capacité par exemple à retourner un
jury sur des ces qui sont parfois
extrêmement difficiles il a été aussi
l'avocat de nombreux politiques il ne
faut jamais l'oublier il a été l'avocat
de Patrick balc il a été l'avocat aussi
de Jérôme
Cahusac lors de son procès donc c'est
quelqu'un qui euh sait aussi abordé des
procès qui peuvent avoir une dimension
politique et la force de j'allais dire
la force de Dupont moriti c'est Dupont
moriti ils sont capital de duupupont
moriti c'est le capital de Dupont moriti
alors on a CE50 qui nous demande on
attend la décision elle devait tomber
comme tar est en train de lui répondre
d'ailleurs elle devait tomber à 15h mais
ça tarde vous aurez les les les images
et la décision dès qu'ell tombe promis
on a un interna qui demande de répéter
mais que reproche-t-on exactement à Éric
Dupont metti on lui reproche tout
simplement on reproche à son à son
administration d'avoir fait pression
dans la fameuse affaire des fadetes sur
un certain nombre de magistrat la
fameuse affaire des fadettes qui a été
l'affaire pour laquelle Nicolas Sarkozi
a été amé je crois en première instance
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il était condamné
en deème instance il faudrait vérifier
effectivement on disait aussi dans tous
les cas Éric Dupont Mourti ne sortirait
pas indem est-ce que même si il était
blanchi à quitté est-ce qu' est-ce qu'il
serait est-ce qu'il pourrait est-cece
que tout redeviendrait normal finalement
bah ce qui est la rité c'est
que finalement moi c'est ce qui me
frappe dans cette affaire c'est que le
maintien de du pont Moretti au poste de
garde des saut a visé finalement d'une
certaine manière à banaliser ce type de
poursuite en d'autres termes tant que il
n'est pas condamné le ministre peut
rester en poste je ne suis pas sûr que
si vous voulez dans d'autres démocraties
euh proche de nous cela se soit passé de
la même manière je pense qu'il y a
quelque part malgré tout aujourd'hui une
forme d'exception française moi je suis
finalement assez frappé dans cette
affaire et c'est ça PE peut-être le plus
important c'est que il y a d'abord une
relative indifférence ce qui aurait pu
faire scandale il y a peut-être 20 ans
en l'occurrence finalement a eu assez
peu d'impact y compris sur le plan
médiatique certes nous en parlons mais
je n'ai pas vu quand même les opposition
euh demandé de manière insistante c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire la démission
du garde des saau je n'ai pas vu si vous
voulez une campagne de presse qui soit
telle qu'elle pousse le garde des saau à
devoir s'expliquer constamment euh il y
a une forme en effet me semble-t-il
d'indifférence qui s'est installée ce
qui n'est pas forcément un très bon
signe pour la démocratie euh comme si
finalement en dernière instance c'était
les électeurs et les électrices qui lors
des élections devaient trancher et et
décider sauf que Monsieur Dupont mouriti
n'est candidat à rien et que il y a
quand même quelque chose de paradoxal à
ce que le ministre de la Justice soit
lui-même poursuivi par sa propre
administration il y a quelque chose qui
peut en effet choquer même si quand même
faut-il le rappeler la présomption
d'innocence s'applique à Monsieur Dupont
moréti comme tout justiciable bien sûr
en d'autrre terme on a si vous voulez on
a abandonné une forme de jurisprudence
j'aime pas trop cette expression parce
que c'est pas une vraie jurisprudence au
sens juridique du terme mais en tout cas
une jurisprudence sur le plan j'allais
dire de la pratique c'est que
depuis les années bgovois lorsqu'il
était Premier ministre et Édouard
Baladur tout ministre qui était ne
serait-ce que
soupçonner judiciairement devait
démissionner de sa fonction pour tout
simplement avoir la liberté de se
défendre j'allais dire de manière
beaucoup plus confortable c'est vrai que
c'est beaucoup plus simple pour un
justiciable de se défendre lorsquil n'a
pas une responsabilité politique qui va
le
surexposer on voit que avec Emmanuel
Macron depuis finalement 2017 on a
progressivement abandonné cette
jurisprudence je pense que sur la durée
ça crée quand même si vous voulez des
dégâts dans l'opinion publique et que le
lien de confiance entre la classe
politique et euh l'opinion publique qui
est un lien de confiance dont on sait
qu'il est particulièrement distendu
depuis de nombreuses années euh je pense
que ça ça indéiablement ça renforce
cette j'allais dire cette cette défiance
oui vous parlez aussi de faire sa
défense et c'est aussi polluer
finalement l'action du gouvernement
puisque on a aujourd'hui un gouvernement
à qui on parle beaucoup de Éric d pomti
d'Olivier du alors oui ce qu'il faut
signaler c'est que il y a un autre
ministre qui est jugé qui est devant la
Cour de Justice de la République c'est
le Ministre également c'est le ministre
c'est le Ministre du du travail donc en
effet alors d'une certaine manière ça
montre que la justice fonctionne et que
elle s'applique pour tous les iable que
nous sommes que nous soyons ministres ou
que N nous le soyons pas force de
constater que d'ailleurs
elle agit assez vite parce que bon on
peut pas considérer que l'instruction de
ce dossier du pont moréti comme
l'instruction du dossier Olivier du
sopte est véritablement traîné même si
ça a pris du temps donc ça c'est plutôt
un signe qui est un signe j'allais dire
de d'une certaine manière de bonne santé
démocratique encore une fois le vrai
problème mais de savoir si un ministre
doit rester en fonction lorsque il est
en délicatesse lorsqu'il est en
délicatesse avec la justice là ça pose
un vrai problème j'allais dire à la
limite c'est presque de la
responsabilité d'abord personnelle du
ministre mais c'est aussi la
responsabilité de ceux qui le nomment
c'est-à-dire le président de la
République et euh la première ministre
en l'occurrence effectivement et vous
avez parlé aussi des de de l'étranger on
parle souvent des autres pays en disant
mais en France au moindre enfin dans les
autres pays au moindre soupçon il serait
déjà parti on a ces notamment ces
exemples de de d'hommes politiques dans
le dans les pays plutôt du Nord qui qui
démissionne on va dire très rapidement à
la moindre affaire est- est-ce que c'est
vraiment le cas par rapport à la France
ah oui très clairement je je je je crois
qu'aujourd'hui si vous voulez euh quand
on regarde le fonctionnement des
démocraties
voisines nos les les politiques dans nos
dans les démocraties voisines je pense
bien évidemment vous avez cité les
démocraties scandinaves mais on pourrait
parler de la démocratie allemande on
pourrait parler également du Royaume-Uni
mais on pourrait parler aussi des
démocratie du Sud latine c'est-à-dire
l'Espagne et l'Italie euh la notion me
semble-t-il aujourd'hui de
responsabilité politique me paraît en
tout cas euh beaucoup plus pointilleuse
qu'elle ne l'ai euh qu'elle ne l'ai
qu'elle ne l'est en France est-ce que
c'est l'héritage de la tradition
monarchique qui explique en France
finalement cette distance je n'en suis
pas sûr je crois que c'est plutôt une
évolution récente parce que quand on
regarde sur les 30 dernières années il y
avait eu quand même la volonté même
depuis François miteron on a parlé de
Pierre bgovois depuis Jacques
Chirac et puis évidemment depuis les les
autres présidents de la république
Nicolas Sarkozi de François Hollande de
couper les branches tout de suite plutôt
que de conserver des ministres dont
finalement euh la la la suspicion qu'il
pouvait tourner autour d'eux était
gênante à la fois pour leur action mais
aussi pour l'ensemble du gouvernement
François hande a dit d'ailleurs une
chose assez juste il a dit ça peut
parfois paraître ça pouvait parfois
paraître injuste mais c'était nécessaire
et en effet de toute façon à un moment
donné il y a dans l'action politique et
dans la fonction politique des devoirs
qui me paraissent important alors les
gens sortent de la salle et
l'information est tombée le ministre de
la Justice éc du P mtier é relaxé par la
CJR donc voilà nous nous attendons les
les les premières réactions à cette à
cette relaxe est-ce que vous êtes
surpris dans cette relaxe je ne suis euh
non je ne suis pas plus surpris mais euh
il faut d'abord il faudra il faudra
savoir quel est le décomte des voix
c'est important
euh moi sur le sur le sur le fond du
dossier je n'ai pas d'élément qui me
permettent d'apprécier objectivement la
décision de la Cour de Justice de la
République euh en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que euh pour Monsieur Dupont
moriti c'est certainement un soulagement
et c'est aussi un soulagement pour la
première ministre et le président de la
République parce qu'une condamnation eû
entraîné de facto euh la démission
vraisemblablement euh du euh garde des
saau en l'occurrence après cette
décision le garde des saut euh va euh
sans aucun doute rester euh en fonction
h non là maintenant là maintenant
effectivement il va rester en fonction
mais jusqu'à quand et puis on le disait
aussi depuis le début de ce live c'est
que les les les relations avec euh avec
les magistrats se sont pas forcément
améliorés avec un procès comme celui-là
non certainement pas mais il est pas le
premier si vous voulez garde des sauts
avoir des difficultés dans ses relations
avec les magistrats donc là-dessus il
les a géré il les a géré non sont
difficulté mais il les a géré et on peut
imaginer qu'il continuera à les gérer
alors ave du P arrive nous allons
écouter sa déclaration sil déclare
quelque chose
d'ailleurs vous vu qui passe sans faire
de déclaration nous allons écouter ce
que disent les
avocats
regarde c'est c'est c'est ce que l'on
espérait c'est ce que le droit
dictait c'est évidemment une
satisfaction et je dirais même une
émotion
énorme la Cour de Justice de la
République a jugé que le ministre de la
Justice Éric Dupont Moretti était
innocent
la Cour de Justice de la
République est venu dire
que depuis 3
ans il avait été m en cause
injustement il avait été désigné comme
un coupable avant même d'avoir été jugé
d'une prise illégale d'intérêt qui en
réalité n'a jamais
existé donc au terme de ces de semaines
de débat de ces de semaines de
délibérer innocence d'éc DUP moréti
qu'il clamé depuis le premier jour avec
ses
avocats a été démontrée et elle est
aujourd'hui consacrée je voudrais quand
même vous dire à tous que pendant toutes
ces années il était désigné et présenté
comme un coupable avant tout procès je
voudrais vous dire aussi que pendant
toutes ces années beaucoup trop de
personnes ont considéré que la messe
était dite alors que la justice n'avait
pas encore été rendue la justice est
rendue aujourd'hui elle a déclaré le
garde des saut innocent des fait qui lui
était reproché c'est donc un terme qui
est mis à ces années d'accusation sans
preuve et à ces années d'accusation sans
fondement je vous je voudrais je
voudrais juste vous dire aussi une chose
c'est que pour nous
c'est d'abord la
consécration de la prééminence du procès
judiciaire
euh et et l'exclusion de tous les autres
procès pour nous c'est la victoire du
droit c'est la victoire de la
présomption d'innocence mais c'est aussi
quelque part aujourd'hui la victoire de
la séparation des
pouvoirs je voudrais aussi vous dire
que c'est la victoire d'un homme non pas
contre une institution euh c'est
peut-être je l'espère et nous l'appelons
de nos vœux le temps de la Concorde
retrouvver dans la famille
judiciaire et peut-être je l'espère
l'acceptation que aujourd'hui justice a
été rendue que le droit a triomphé et
que la justice a triomphé voilà ce que
je voulais dire dans l'intérêt d'Éric du
pont morétique nous avons eu avec réy
Laurin qui va vous dire quelques mots
vraiment le grand honneur de
défendre je m'appelle jaquine
la cette décision confirme également
s'il en était encore besoin que Éric
Dupont Moretti n'a jamais souhaité à
aucun moment se venger contre quiconque
c'est évidemment une décision qu'on
accueille avec beaucoup de satisfaction
avec ma consœur Jacquine Laffond mais
sans surprise cette décision est une
surprise uniquement pour les gens qui
ont sans doute mal compris mal
appréhendé ce ce dossier ce dossier
était vide ce dossier ne permettait pas
de poursuite pénale de Monsieur le
Ministre l'innocence qui était c'est
évidente et manifeste dès le premier
jour de ce dossier est consacré
aujourd'hui judiciairement on ne peut
que s'en réjouir nous vous remercions on
nira pas plus loin aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous répondez
auput
suppression matériel de l'élément
intentionnel comment vous l'alz je
voudrais juste dire qu'il n'y a pas
d'infraction sans élément moral et
matériel donc voilà non mais enfin c'est
aussi simple que ça il y a deux éléments
constitutifs l'un sans l'autre ne fait
pas une infraction donc il n'y a pas
d'infraction aujourd'hui c'est ce que la
Cour vient de dire on ne peut plus
clairement merci
merci voilà vous venez d'entendre les
avocats thri dupetti Jacqueline Lafond
et réy
Laurin vous l'avez entendu déjà une
première chose é étonnante c'est que ce
n'est pas éc Moretti qui s''estexprimé
il a laissé ses avocats faire oui il a
laissé ses avocats parler à sa place ce
qui en soi n'est pas surprenant ce qui
était très intéressant c'est la sortie
de Monsieur Dupont Moretti on voyait
bien que le pas qui était le sien était
le pas d'un homme soulangé et qui était
en train malgré tout de profiter de ce
moment de libération et vraécment c'est
la raison pour laquelle il a préféré
laisser ses conseils communiquer à sa
place qui d'ailleurs est assez habile
parce que ça lui permet ça lui évite de
devoir réagir à chaud à une décision de
justice quand bien même cette décision
justice lui est favorable ça c'est le
premier point deuxème point ce qui me
paraît en effet important et la la
l'avocate de Monsieur Dupont Moretti l'a
rappelé c'est vrai que c'est une
victoire du droit en l'occurrence mais
il y a un autre aspect et là elle peut
évidemment ne pas le dire parce que ce
n'est pas à elle de le dire c'est une
victoire politique aussi pour elle c'est
une victoire politique aussi pour
Monsieur Dupont m vous pouvez continuer
à écouter les
réactions CHR je suis l'avocat du ndic
de la magistrature et de l'Union
Syndicale des
Magistrats j'aimerais dire qu'à la
lecture de la
décision il se constate que l'ensemble
de la procédure commencée au mois
d'octobre 2020 a permis à la démocratie
et à la transparence de faire de grands
progrès en
effet le Ministre de la Justice au
moment de sa désignation niit
l'existence de tout conflit d'intérêt
dans les termes les plus absolus plus
ferme la décision dans des termes
dépourvus d'équivoque a relevé à deux
reprises l'existence de conflits
d'intérêts manifestes ces conflits
d'intérêts devaient le conduire à se
déporter dans ses actes au profit du
Premier
ministre cela a fini par être fait à
notre sens cela avait été fait
tardivement mais cela a été fait
aujourd'hui ce conflit d'intérêt qui
était nié est reconnu cela signifie qu'à
l'avenir le comportement
d'ti consistant à ne pas reconnaître ces
conflits d'intérêt ne pourra pas se
reproduire ni pour lui-même ni pour
d'autres ministres ni pour d'autres
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
c'est une avancée majeure dont on ne
peut que se
féliciter la Cour de Justice de la
République a également décider que
nayant pas conscience de l'infraction
qui lu éta reproché celle-ci ne pouvait
être
établie les organisations syndicales en
prennent acte elles n'ont pas à se
prononcer sur cette décision de justice
l'essentiel c'est que ce qu'elles ont
toujours demandé depuis l'origine à
savoir la reconnaissance de ces conflits
d'intérêt a été judiciaairement établi
c'est essentiel nous en prenons acte et
nous sommes heureux que pour l'avenir de
tel phénomène de tel conflit ne puisse
se reproduire je vous remercie votre nom
Monsieur Votre nom Christophe claire je
suis l'avocat du Syndicat de la
magistrature et de l'Union Syndicale des
Magistrats merci bienme important de
souligner l'élément institutionnel n'a
pas été retenu c'est bien c'est c'est
bien ce que j'ai dit nous en prenons
acte cela résulte des débats alors je
rajouterai un deuxième élément c'est que
la procédure de la Cour de Justice de la
République est une procédure
imparfaite cela ne me conduit pas à
remettre en cause la décision soyons
clair je parle ici pour
l'avenir ce qui se passe c'est que les
plaignant et les victimes c'est
important les victimes ne peuvent pas
être représenté leur voix ne peut pas
être entendue ils n'ont pas accès au
dossier ils ne peuvent pas demander
d'acte ils ne peuvent pas interroger les
témoins ils ne peuvent pas être assistés
quand ils sont entendus ils ne peuvent
pas plaider cette forme de justice est
une
demijustice nous souhaitons pour
l'avenir et encore je le répète sans
remettre en cause sur ce fondement la
décision qui a été rendue nous
souhaitons pour l'avenir que cette
imperfection de notre système juridique
pour une cour de justice qui est
essentielle au fonctionnement de la
République soit corrigée et nous en
appelons à toutes les parties prenantes
intéressées par la justice en France de
se saisir du débat pour trancher enfin
une question qui fait l'objet de
discussion de longue date mais qui n'a
jusqu'à présent jamais progressé c'est
que vous espérez que le parquet ce
pourvoit en cassation nous n'avons pas à
espérer ou ne pas espérer sur ce sujet
c'est le rôle du parquet que de prendre
des décisions nous avons toujours dit
que notre objectif c'était la
reconnaissance du conflit d'intérêt
c'est fait vous avez pas le sentiment
que c'est un désaveux pour Syndicat de
la magistrature cette décision ce n'est
aucunement un des aveux c'est bien au
contraire une façon de conforter
l'analyse du Syndicat de la magistrature
et de l'Union Syndicale des Magistrats
et de FO magistrat qui avait fait un
signalement et de anticorps et de la
grande majorité des tribunaux plutôt la
majorité des tribunaux de France qui
avaient dénoncé le conflit d'intérêt se
voit conforter dans leur analyse de
l'existence d'un conflit d'intérêt qui
dans des termes non dénués d'ambigué éta
nié à répétition par le garde de desau
de l'époque cette position est
aujourd'hui infirmé par la décision de
la Cour de Justice de la républiqueelui
que vous voyez comme coupable voilà vous
l'avez
entendu l'avocat du syndicat de
l'ministrature qui se félicite lui aussi
malgré la relaxe
de par la C an on a été quand même bien
entendu oui c'està-dire qu'en fait
l'argument de l'avocat des des syndicats
et de dire la la la la notion de conflit
d'intérêt a été reconnue mais finalement
l'acquittement de Monsieur Dupont moréti
est lié au fait qu'il n'y avait pas d'
d'intentionnalité de la part ou qu' n'en
était pas conscient donc ils peuvent
considérer de ce point de vue-là que
c'est une demi- victoire mais c'est
plutôt qu me me semble-t-il plus un
effet de rhétorique de la part de de la
de la de la de l'avocat parce que de
fait ce que l'on retient quand même ce
soir c'est que Monsieur Dupont moriti a
été acquitté alors il faudrait quand
même savoir quel a été le décompte des
vois je crois que ça serait important
moi je l'ai pas à ce stade pour savoir
exactement quel est le rapport de force
qui était à l'intérieur de la CJR pour
jugé monsieur Dupont Moretti cet
après-midi oui on le saura aussi il a
aussi forcé parler de la cégir j'en
profite parce que à l'Assemblée les les
les les membres de la de de les
parlementaires en sortant de de de de
séance ont déjà réagi et notamment LFI
qui demande la suppression de la CGR oui
mais c'est pas nouveau ce n'est pas la
première fois que que LFI ou que
d'autres formations politiques demandent
la suppression de la CJR encore une fois
c'est vrai que il faut s'en souvenir que
Monsieur Macron je crois dans sa
campagne de 2017 peut-être pas dans sa
campagne de 2022 avait en effet
considérer qu'il fallait d'une certaine
manière supprimer cette instance qui est
considérée par beaucoup de nos
concitoyens s vrai d'une certaine façon
comme une instance d'exception mais
peut-être que ça fera l'objet d'une
révision constitutionnelle car comme
vous le savez le président de la
République réfléchit maintenant sur une
révision constitutionnelle mais il
faudrait évidemment pour le coup que
l'exécutif puisse disposer d'une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale pour
cette réforme constitutionnelle et qu'
exactement quel est le contenu de cette
réforme constitutionnelle h alors
écit-il relaxé par sgir est-ce que on
peut s'attendre néanmoins à ce que ça
bouge au sein du du du du
gouvernement très difficile de lire à ce
stade il y a des rumeurs qui ont circulé
ces derniers jours sur les intention du
président de la République de de de de
faire bouger son mécano gouvernemental
mais y y a-t-il intérêt politiquement
dans le moment certainement pas parce
que il y a une raison qui est évidente
qui est liée d'abord au fait que euh on
on rentre en discussion à l'Assemblée
nationale sur le projet de loi
immigration donc je ne vois pas au
moment où on rentre en discussion sur un
projet de loi dont on sait qu'il sera
particulièrement difficile à faire
adopter par l'Assemblée nationale sans
user du
493 le président de la
République changer de gouvernement même
le faire bouger à la marge ce n'est pas
me semble-t-il son intérêt et le timing
me paraît pas en tout cas à ce stade
opportun et approprié a-t-il ensuite si
l'on essaie d'avancer un peu plus avant
dans le calendrier intérêt à faire
bouger son gouvernement avant les
élections européennes de 2024 là aussi
la question me paraît se poser parce que
il vaut mieux parfois attendre si vous
voulez une redistribution du rapport de
force politique pour essayer de donner
un nouvel élan à une équipe
gouvernementale alors après évidemment
toute la question est de savoir si
contenu de la majorité relative très
relative à l'Assemblée nationale ce
gouvernement peut encore tenir longtemps
dans les les conditions des rapports de
force que l'on connaît aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale de ce point de
vue-là je pense que le texte en
discussion sur l'immigration sera un bon
indicateur un indicateur est-ce que
Emmanuel Macron sort quelque part un peu
vainqueur def en tout cas il ilessort
renforcé vu que éric dtier a été relaxé
alors je sais pas s'il sort renforcé
mais par contre en effet quelque part on
peut considérer que la décision de la
cour de justice de la République vient
valider sa stratégie d'avoir
maintenu monsieur Dupont moriti à son
poste quel que soit la suspicion
judiciaire qu'il pouvait peser sur lui
donc il n'a pas à regretter en tout cas
le le le le le le fait de l'avoir
maintenu cette décision lui évite une
crise cette décision lui évite en effet
d'être contestée si euh et Monsieur
Dupont moriti avait été condamné
évidemment on lui aurait reproché
d'avoir pendant tout ce temps maintenu
jusqu'à la condamnation monsieur Dupont
morti le fait qu'il ne soit pas condamné
bah quelque part vient valider en tout
cas sa stratégie d'ailleurs duont il
sera érici sera reçu cet après-midi par
Emmanuel Macron ça vient de tomber c'est
un signe important ça veut dire qu'il va
lui
renouveler c'est le moyen de de de de de
montrer la part du président de la
République qui lui renouvelle
en tout cas fortement sa confiance sauf
surprise sauf surprise effectivement on
suivra ça bien évidemment j'en profite
aussi puisque je viens de voir une une
dépêche surj mais Olivier du qui en ce
moment je pour fa le ministre du Travail
10 mois d'emprisonnement avec surc ont
été requis contre lui ça VI tomber aussi
à la FP on attendraend on attendra aussi
la décision pour voir ce qui se passera
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes politolog prur
associé à la sbonne et récteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi et je
vous souhaite une bonne fin de journée
sur le site du
Figo bon ça a été super ouais parfait ok
parfait ils sont arriver un peu plus
tard que prévu mais bon ça va on a pas
le le le le le
vote que ça s jouer à une Brit
prè il chaud mais c'était en fait
c'était ce qui se c'était ce qui se
disait bah oui c'est ça il
est
voà B
arrivag